comment est-ce qu'un machin aussi énorme
dirait une créature d'un film d'horreur
de science fiction il sensé me rassure
et hussein sam c'est toujours l'amour de
ma vie
félicitations pour vous faire sa santé à
d'autres imaginent si ça n'allait pas
marcher c'est pas possible j'ai une
nouvelle difficile avoue à l'examen
sanguin a révélé que n'est pas censé
être un grand changement est toujours
marquée par un moment précis présence
d'une masse il s'agit bien d'un concert
c'était ça le moment moins on n'aura pas
à payer ses études
à moins que ce soit une tumeur hyper
intelligente bienvenue dans le pire
groupe dont tu pourras faire partie
d'entre eux est elle utile coup j'espère
qu'elle continuera à y aller quand je
serai plus là avec le nouveau cas
qu'elle se tapera bien sûr bienvenue
dans le groupe tiens tu peux déjà
installés ici j'arrête guillemin billets
dit ça pour lui dire que ça valait des
circuits que je sais c'est qu'il n'est
pas encore morte
j'essaie juste d'avoir une approche
positive et les jolies d'amérique
les vrais cheveux si une catastrophe qui
a sortie ratée chaussettes serait de
bruit et si c'est pas le cadre j'étais
en train d'envoyer des textos suis
réaliste ça m'a toutes ces filles vont
jeter sur lui tu as eu envie qui l'a
jamais dragué trophy pente trop jolie
j'ai décidé d'arrêter plus t'es ok si tu
finis pas aller mieux tout sortir viacom
pour fait le droit de me parler comme ça
suivante
non non non arrête te fatigue pas
complètement morte de trouille à la
forcément besoin de savoir que tu t'en
sortir est bien sans elle je n'arrive
pas à croire que tu essaies de me caser
ils pressent encore moins de temps qu
est ce que tu crois c'est vrai pour toi
je c'est vrai pour tous les gens du
monde entier est anticipée pour lui que
tu es en train de louper la meilleure
partie
je pensais que si je planifiais tout ton
avenir pour toi ça me ferait moins de
mal de savoir que je n'en ferai pas
partie
[Musique]
pourquoi toutes ces choses qu'on fait
pour les gens qu'on aime
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]